While many of us go through life
with the persuit of money on our minds,
we're often told that
money can't buy happiness.
But what truth is
there in the saying?
Is there a correlation
between money and happiness?
And, if so, how can we use
it to our advantage?
Humans are very
sensitive to change.
When we get a raise or
commission, we really enjoy it.
But we adapt at incredible
speeds to our new wealth.
Some studies have shown
that in North America,
additional income beyond $75.000 a year
ceases to impact day-to-day happiness.
In fact, people who win the lottery often
report becoming extremely unhappy.
They often end up spending
all the money, going into debt
and experience ruined
social relationships.
So, surely money can't
really buy happiness.
Well, recent studies suggest that
the problem may actually be
in the way we spend money.
Instead of buying things for yourself,
try giving some of it to other people
and see how you feel.
Studies show that people who spend
their money on others feel happier.
And while people who
spend it on themselves
don't necessarily become less happy,
their happiness is unchanged.
The same principle has been tested
on teams and organizations as well.
One experiment showed that
instead of an organization writing
a large check to a charity, dividing
the amount up amongst employees
and allowing them to contribute
to a charity of their choosing,
increased their job satisfaction.
Similarly, individuals that spend
monetary incentives on each other,
as opposed to themselves,
increase not only job satisfaction,
but improve team
performance and sales.
This has been seen in both
sales and sports teams.
Almost everywhere we look
in the world, we see that
giving money or gifts to others is
possitively correlated with happiness.
Interestingly, the specific way the
money is spent on others isn't important.
From trivial gifts to major charity
efforts, spending something
on others is the important aspect
in increasing your happiness.
The emotional rewards of pro-social spending
are even detectable at the neural level.
If you are going to spend the money
on yourself, try to go after experiences,
as opposed to material things.
Traveling or going to an event is more impactful
for the vast majority of people in the long run.
And while you're saving up
for these big experiences,
don't forget about
the daily joys in life.
Many small frequent pleasures help
to get you through the days and
and encourage change,
which stimulates the brain.
Instead of buying a 3,000-dollar rug that provides
a one-time experience for the next 10 years,
a 5-dollar latte with friends
will be different each time,
offering unique access to
happiness opportunities.
Though money is unlikely to be the
main source of happiness in our lives,
it certainly has the potential to make some
things easier... and complicate others.
But at the end of the day, it can buy
happiness, if spent in the right way.
Got a burning question
you want answered?
Ask it in the comments or
on facebook and twitter.
And subscribe for more
Weekly Science videos.